المحكمه
في نظرت في زعم جنوب افريقيا بين اسرائيل
قد انتهكت التزاماتها وجنوب افريقيا اشارت
بان اسرائيل قد انتهكت التزامات اخرى ايضا
بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده جمعيه ب ذلك مباع
القلق حول التواطئ والتامر ارتكاب الاباده
جماعيه والتاجي الراي العام من اجل ارتكاب
الجماعيه وايضا ال الارتكاب الفعلي
للاباده الجماعيه وفي مداولات ال
[موسيقى]
محكمه كان
هنالك مراج دفوع من قبل الاطراف
حول هذه
الانتهاكات وبناء على
الطلب كلفت المحكمه من اجل النظره فيما
اذا كان هنالك ما يرقى او
ما يصل الى الانتهاك الاتفاقيه العباده
الجماعيه وجهه نظر المحكمه على الاقل
بعض المزعم التي قدمتها جنوب افريقيا متكا
ما تكته اسرائيل في جنوب غزه قد تكون
واقعه لبنود الاتفاقيه وقد خلصت المحكمه
الى ان الواجهه القضائيه والاختصاصي وفقا
للماده ت من الاتفاقيه تستطيع النظري في
المحكمه واخذين عن اعتبار هذه الخلاصه ترى
المحكمه بانها لا يمكنها
تقبل قلب اسرائيل برد الدعوه وتحولت
المحكمه الى السؤال الثاني الى طلب جنوب
افريقيا واشارت
بان الطرف المدعي في ما يتعلق باتفاقيه
الاباده
الجماعيه وفي قضيه جامبيا ضد ميانمار
والماده ت من الاتفاقيه ايضا
تم تفعيلها المحكمه لاحظت بان اشارت بان
جميع الاطراف الموقعين عندهم مصلحه مشتركه
في التاكد من منع ومعاقبه كل جرم من
الاباده الجماعيه وعبر الالتزام تجاه هذا
هذه الاتفاقيه وبنودها مثل هذه المصالح
المشتركه تتضمن
بان كل دوله طرف هي مسؤوله تجاه كل الدول
الاخرى وبالوفاء
بالتزاماتها من حي ناحيه ان كل دوله طرف
عندها مصلحه بالت
بكل قضيه مطروحه وفيما يتعلق بالامتثال
بالواجبات موجب الاتفاقيه تشير الى ان اي
دوله طرف ومن دون اي تمييز لها الحق
في رفع دعوه ضد اي دوله اخرى فيما يتعلق
بم الوفاء بالتزاماتها وفقا عليه وجدت
المحكمه الى ان دوله مصادقه او مقع
الاتفاقيه ال يمكن لها ان تقوم
بالادعاء المحكمه ومن اجل
البت هذه المحكمه فيما اذا كان هنالك
انتهاك
للاتفاقيه والمحكمه خلصت ايضا لوجود
الاختصاص وان جنوب افريقيا عندها لها الحق
في رفع لهذه
المحكمه قضيه تتعلق بانتهاك اسرائيل
لالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه وعندها تحولت المحكمه الى الحقوق
وحمايه الحقوق رابط ما بين هذه الحقوق
والتدابير المطلوب فرضها
والمحكمه وفق الماده 41 من ميثاقها
لها
الحق للبت في هذه الحقوق المزعوم انتهاكها
من الاطراف و وقد والمحكمه ينبغي عليها ان
تقوم باللجوء الى هذه التدابير اذا كان
هنالك انتهاك للحقوق لاي طرف من اطراف
الدول المصادقه وعليه المحكمه يمكن ان
تمارس سلطاتها فقط اذا كانت
قد اقتنعت بما تقدمه الدوله المدعيه وحتى
الان في هذه المرحله المحكمه غير قادره
على اطلاق
حكم قطعي فيما ان الحكوم التي سعت ج افريق
لتحقيقها
قد ثبتت و وعلاوه على ذلك ينبغي ان يكون
هنالك رابط ما بين الحقوق التي تسعى الى
حمايتها والتدابير التي سعي ل تحقيقها
والمحكمه تقول بانها بموجب الماده 41 من
الاتفاقيه على جميع الاطراف المصدقين ان
يقوموا بالتعهد بمعاقبه جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه
والماده تشير بان الاباده الجماعيه تعني
بان اي من الافعال التاليه التي ارتكبت من
اجل
تدمير مجموعات
عرقيه غيره من ذلك قتل اعضاء المجموعه
وباء التسبب بضرر نفسي او بدني لاعضاء
المجموعه
وجيم خلق ظروف حياه من قبل مجموعات مسلحه
تؤدي
الى تعطيل حياه الناس وايذائهم
ودال اجبار ونقل اطفال المجموعه الى
مجموعات اخرى نهايه
الاقتباس وفقا ثلاثه من الاباده الجماعيه
الافعال التاليه ايضا محظوره وفقا
للاتفاقيه التامر لارتكاب الاباده
الجماعيه التاجج العام من اجل ارتكاب
الجرام الجماعيه ومحاوله ارتكاب الجما
الاباده الجماعيه والتواطؤ ايضا في جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه اذا شروط الاتفاقيه تسعى
الى حمايه مجموعات وطنيه او عرقيه او
دينيه من ايه افعال اباده جماعيه او غيرها
من افعال المعاقب عليها بموجب البند
الثالث والمحكمه ترى بان هنالك علاقه ما
بين حقوق اعضاء المجموعه المحميين
باتفاقيه اباده جماعيه
والواجبات على الدوله وحق اي دوله طرفي في
السعي لطلب الامتثال منول طرف
اخرى وكما اشارت المحكمه في قضايا اخرى
انه من اجل ان يقع هذا في نطاق الماده
الثانيه من الاتفاقيه ينبغي ووجود النيه
لتدمير جزء كبير من مجموعه بعينها هذا
يتطلب وبطبيعه جريمه الاباده الجماعيه حيث
ان الغرض من هذه الاتفاقيه وجوهرها هو منع
تدمير المقصود للمجموعات او المتعمد
والاستهداف
او استهداف المجموعه يكون ثر على المجموعه
كله والفلسطينيين يبدو بانهم
يشكلون مجموعه وطنيه عرقيه
ومحميه بموجب الماده الثانيه من اتفاقيه
الاباده الجماعيه والمحكمه اقتر بان وفقا
لموارد الامم المتحده ان الشعب الفلسطيني
في قطاع غزه يمثل اكثر من ا 2 مليون شخص
والفلسطيني في قطاع غزه يشكلون جزءا كبيرا
من هذه المجموعه واشارت المحكومه بان
العمليات العسكريه التي تشنها اسرائيل
عقبه هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
2023 والذي ادى الى عدد من الوفيات
والقتلى وايضا دمار شامل ل المنازل واجبار
قصري غلبيه كبيره للسكان وضرر على البنى
التحتيه ضرر كبير جدا وارقام هنا من قطاع
غزه لا يمكن التحقق منها بطريقه مستقله فك
المعلومات الاخيره تشير الى ان
25700 فلسطيني قد قتلوا واكثر من 63 ال
مصاب واكثر من
360 وحده وحده سكنيه قد تدمرت واكثر من
1.7 مليون شخص نزحوا
داخليا المحكمه ايضا اخذت بعين الاعتبار
بيان مساعد الامين العام للامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه والاغاثه منسق الاغاثه
الانسانيه السيد مارتن جريفيث في الخامس
من يناير 2024 واقتبسوا عنه بان غازا قد
تحولت الى مكان للياس والموت العائلات
تنام في العراء ودرجات الحراره تنخفض
والمناطق التي طلب من المدنيين
منصفتش
الطبيه تحت هجوم مستمر كارثه انسانيه
تتكشف امام اعيننا غزه قد اصبحت مكانا لا
يمكن الاقامه فيه والناس يواجهون تهديدات
يوميه على حياتهم ونهايه
الاقتباس وعقب بعثه الى جنوب غزه منظمه
الصحه
العالميه قشرت في ال 21 من ديسمبر بان
هنالك 93% من تعداد سكان غزه يواجهون
مستوى غير مسبوق من المجاعه مع عدم وجود
ما يكفي من الطعام ومستويات عاليه من سوء
التغذيه نهايه الاقتباس المحكمه اخذ بع
الاعتبار ايضا
بيان وكاله الاغاثه الانسانيه او مسمى
بالاون والسيد فيليب لوزرين في الث عش من
يناير 244 واقتبس عنه قد مرت فتره على
بدايه الحرب المدمره
وبعد الهجوم المروع الذي شنته حماش ضد
الشعب الاسرائيلي لقد مر اكثر من 100
يوم ايضا من القلق والرعب على الاسرى و
عائلاتهم ومنذ مئات يوم القصف مستمر على
قطاع غزه والذي تسبب في نزوح كبير
ل السكان و اجبر الناس على مغادره مزهم
بين الت وضحها هي والى ماكن ليست اكثر
امنا من تضرر هم اكثر من مليوني شخص وهم
اجمال ل الشعب في غزه كثير منهم س يتضررون
نفسيا وبدنيا الى الابد وايضا
الاطفال مرعوبون وهنالك
قد اصبحت منشات الاونور وطنا للالاف من
الناس و
يفقدون لا يجدون الطعام ولا
المياه الامراض في تفشي وخاصه بين الاطفال
هم
يعيشون في حياه مريعه والساعه تدق وبالوا
الاطفال ايضا هو يفطر القلوب جيل كامل من
الاطفال مروع وسيحتاج سنوات للتعافي
الالاف وقد قتلوا
ويتم عشرات الالاف لا يجدون ما يقوت يومهم
التداعيات كبير طويله الامد من
هذا ان
ايضا اشارت الامم المتحده بان الازمه في
غزه و
هي تزيد عليها هذه الخطاب الذي ينزع الصفه
الانسانيه